and now Barbara Ehrenreich discusses her
book nickel and dimed about the
difficulty of living adequately in
America on low wages this is about
45-minutes my goodness I gotta say I'm
just a little bit overwhelmed at the
number of you um it looks as if we've
got standing room only so make
yourselves as comfortable as you can I
just can't thank you enough on behalf of
ruminator books for coming out tonight
I'm more than pleased to introduce to
you Barbara Ehrenreich who will be
speaking with us tonight about her
latest book nickel and dimed on not
getting by in boom time America nickel
and dime is the fruit of two years of
experience within the ranks of those
struggling to make ends meet while
working full time jobs paying at or near
minimum wage
simply put MS Ehrenreich decided to test
for herself the truth of welfare reform
rhetoric which promises that a job any
job is the ticket to prosperity and
self-sufficiency
in 1999 and 2000 she left her
comfortable life as a Key West
journalist and moving from Florida to
Maine to right here in Minneapolis she
worked as a waitress a hotel maid a
cleaning woman nursing home aide and
right here a Walmart sales clerk MS Erin
Reich's personal account of her
experience as part of the rank-and-file
low-wage work force illuminates the
darker side of our economy and makes it
impossible to think of those who work to
provide services for us dismissively the
Boston Globe says Ehrenreich scorn
withers her humor stings heretical light
shines on the Chicago Tribune calls her
passionate public hotly lucid and
politically engaged finally the New York
Times raves about nickel and dimed
calling it captivating and just promise
you'll read this explosive little book
cover-to-cover and we'll pass it on to
all your friends and relatives ms
Ehrenreich is a frequent writer for
Harper's Esquire the nation and Time
Magazine's among others
she's also
the author of a number of other books
among them the critically acclaimed fear
of falling and the New York Times
bestseller the worst years of our lives
she lives near Key West Florida now a
little bit of housekeeping about
tonight's reading c-span is taping this
for book TV I'm not sure when it's going
to air I hear it's kind of a gamble but
it will be on TV someday as it turns out
you all have wiped us out of all of our
copies of nickel and dimed but I tell
you we are only too happy to take
reservations for a copy that you'd like
and we'll do everything we can to make
sure that you can get a signed copy also
I have a few of these index cards left
but they're getting precious in number
so if you'd like to ask a question
tonight of miss Ehrenreich because of
the the sheer number and because this is
being taped for television we'll be
handling this via note cards so if you'd
like a note card to ask a question
please hold up your hand as she begins
to talk and I'll come around and give
these to you as long as they last right
before she's finished up I'll collect
the note cards and she'll read your
questions from them and answer them now
the last little bit of housekeeping here
is we got to get her out of here by 9:00
because she's got a flight to catch so I
know as much as we'd all like to bend
her ear just a little bit we got to move
things along as quickly as possible
during the signing to make sure she can
catch that plane so with all of that
said please warmly welcome Barbara
Ehrenreich
thank you thank you for the nice
introduction Susannah and I hope there's
not some mistake there's so many people
here I just want to be sure nobody was
misled by the title this is not an
investment seminar okay I mean yeah I
I've been trying to write about poverty
and especially issues having to do with
women and poverty for many years now and
I want to say I'm just really thrilled
that I have gotten a whole book on this
subject out because it is not easy to
interest the mainstream media in these
sorts of issues and I will tell you one
anecdote to illustrate my frustration
over the years this said this is
something that happened a few years ago
I was taken out to lunch by the editor
of a well-known national magazine which
will go on unnamed here in the interest
of my having a future writing career and
and these lunches are really important
to freelance writers because very often
the cost of the lunch is more than
you're going to be paid you know for the
article so you eat a lot and I was
pitching him an idea a story idea that
had to do with women in poverty and I
had a nice twist to it and I thought it
was a good idea and so on and this
editor was so obviously bored you know
he was kind of rolling his eyes as we
work our way through the gourmet meal I
were having till finally we get to the
you know death by chocolate dessert and
the decaf espressos and he says alright
Barbara do your thing on poverty only
make it upscale this this is the the
attitude there so anyway Susanna I think
explained the idea of this book which
arose in a in a conversation actually
was a much better editor and that is
Lois Laughlin at harper's magazine and i
did not suggest that i do this i just
suggested that somebody do this
and he said you and there I was stuck
and but the idea was basically just to
see at first if it was possible to live
on the wages I could get as an
entry-level worker and this mean meant
leaving home finding a cheap place to
live in the cheapest possible consistent
with some kind of level of safety and
cleanliness and then to find the best
paying job I could although of course I
couldn't use my not using my real resume
or whatever skills that he maybe not
that I ever saw I hope wanted ad for
political SAS anyway so I I don't want
to ruin the story for you the ending or
anything for you but I'll tell you the
result right now which I sort of knew
when I left home just by trying to sit
down and do the math and I could see
that in the particularly area where I
first started out this was Key West day
at the town nearest to where I live and
it's a tourist industry town could see
the wages were going to be in the 6 to
$7 an hour range in 1998 when I started
and I you know could see with the rents
were and it looked like it would be very
very hard to put these things together
and and I think you should bear in mind
that I had a lot of advantages in
undertaking this venture and trying to
support myself for one thing I didn't
have my children with me they're grown
up and they didn't want to kind of live
with mom in a trailer park for a month I
mean they're just not interested in and
whereas you know the average low wage
workers much more likely to have
children to support and take care of I'm
strong and healthy and I always had a
car or a rental wreck and if it was in a
city a strange city so that those are
advantages compared to a lot of people
so the book really turned out to be a
story of how hard it is to not get
anywhere in America how much how hard
you have to work to remain to be part of
the working poor and for me this was
much of it this discovery Susanna told
you the kinds of jobs I had and I'll
talk since this is um with Minneapolis
and the site of one of my attempts to
support myself I'll tell you about more
about my life as a wall Martian that is
at Walmart and I should explain first it
is it is not it's not that easy you know
everybody can get a job at Walmart no
there are things you have to go through
there is the personality test for
example this is mostly these personality
tests are pretty easy you get questions
like oh and this is a proposition you
have to respond to in the past year I
have stolen check dollar amount below
worth of goods from my employers you can
figure that one out right how to answer
that one or my favorite question which
comes up on every personality test
somehow quote true or false it's easier
to work when you're a little bit high
the
you know but my policy my strategy in
taking this personality test was always
to you know I don't usually tell the
right answer but not to be so blatantly
right every time that it was like looked
like I was faking out the test so I'd
always you know modify it a little bit
so I can't you know it actually I've got
some wrong for that reason here in the
Twin Cities area the personnel manager
had given me the test and she said don't
worry there's no right or wrong answers
just whatever you think and then she
goes off to grade it mind you on a
computer and comes back and says that I
got some things wrong and one of them
was the proposition was all rules must
be followed to the letter at all times
and I did not agree totally I only
agreed strongly you know again not
wanting to look like too much of the
syrup well she said the answer is
totally you can never be too much of a
suck-up at Walmart
and no there's more you know you have to
pass the drug test
that's interesting a little ritual of
humiliation you know can you pee for us
please but anyway I passed that one with
flying colors and I got the job seven
dollars an hour in ladieswear which I
thought was going to be very genteel I
thought I was going to be giving fashion
tips to ladies it turned out to be total
drudgery the challenge was to learn
where every single one of hundreds of
items went and you know and there on the
floor there in the there all over the
place and of course then they would be
rotated every three or four days just to
give you the feeling you were slipping
into Alzheimer's and I I think I would
just give you a little reader a little
bit about the orientation for Walmart
associates remember there are no
employees at Walmart and what we're does
into think it's the largest employer in
the United States there are no employees
associates and the customers are often
called guests
so um I'll just give you a little sample
of this experience for sheer grandeur
scale and intimidation value I doubt if
any corporate orientation exceeds that
of Walmart I had been told that the
process will take 8 hours which will
include 2 15 inch breaks and 1/2 hour
break for a meal and will be paid for
but like a regular shift when I arrive
dressed neatly in khakis and clean
t-shirt as befits a Walmart associate I
find there are 10 new hires besides
myself mostly young and Caucasian and a
team of three headed by Roberta the
personnel manager I got in trouble with
to do the orientating as she calls it we
sit around a long table in a windowless
room each with a thick folder of
paperwork in front of us and he Roberta
again give us a pep talk about being a
people person and how important that was
to work at Walmart we begin with a video
about 15 minutes long on the history and
philosophy of Walmart or as an
anthropologist might with if they were
observing they call it the cult of Sam
first young Sam Walton in uniform comes
back from the war he starts a store sort
of five-and-dime he marries and fathers
for attractive children he receives a
medal of freedom from President Bush the
earlier one after which he promptly dies
making way for the eulogies but the
company goes on yes indeed and then we
go you know it goes through you know we
go through this long video about all
these milestones in the corporate
expansion you know when sales topped 100
billion dollars and so on each landmark
date is accompanied by a clip showing
throngs of shoppers swarms of associates
or scenes of handsome new stores and
their adjoining parking lots over and
over we hear in voiceover or see and
graphic display that's the quote three
principles which are of Walmart which
are maddeningly even defiantly
non-parallel
respect for the individual exceeding
customers expectations strive for
excellence and anyway we you know it all
is not total
skipping a little bit here all is not
total harmony we learn a lot about how
important we associates are we learned
that eat was it actually an associate
who invented the idea of the people
greeter that's what we're told and you
know the person who greets you as you
can the real function of the people
greeter by the way is to see that you
don't shoplift to put you on notice for
that in all is not total harmony we're
we're told by the way that managers are
servant leaders they're not bosses
they're servant leaders but then we have
a video on quote associate honesty which
shows a cashier being caught on
videotape as he pockets some bills from
a cash register drums beat ominously as
he is led away in handcuffs and
sentenced to four years this theme of
covert tensions overcome by right
thinking and positive attitude continues
in a 12-minute video entitled you've
picked a great place to work here
various associates testify to the
essential feeling of family for which
Walmart is so well-known quote leading
up to the conclusion that we don't need
a union once the video explained long
ago unions had a place in American
society but they quote no longer have
much to offer workers which is why
people are quote leaving them by that
the droves
and then it goes on and on about the
evils of unions until you have to wonder
and I imagine some of my teenage fellow
or ents may be wondering right now why
such things as these union organizers
such rout outright extortionists are
allowed to roam free in the land there
is more much more than I could ever
absorb you know we we go through this
handbook for a long time
berry the seventeen-year-old to my left
mutters that his butt hurts Sonia the
tiny african-american woman across from
me seems frozen in terror I have given
up on looking perky and I'm fighting to
keep my eyes open
no nose or facial jewelry we learn
earrings must be small and discreet not
dangling no blue jeans except on Friday
and then you have to
dollar for the privilege of wearing them
no grazing that is eating from food
packages that somehow have become open
and no time theft this last idea times
that that sends me drifting off in a
sci-fi direction and as the time thieves
headed back to the Year 3420 loaded with
with weekends and days off looted from
the 21st century finally someone asks a
question the old guy who's being hired
as a people breeder wants to know what
is time theft answer doing anything
anything at all except for working
during company daytime theft of our time
however is not an issue there are
stretches amounting to many minutes when
all three of our trainers wander off
leaving us to sit there in silence or go
through a section of site you know or to
take the chance to fidget a little bit I
have seen time move more swiftly during
seven-hour airline delays in fact I am
getting nostalgic about seven-hour
airline delays
at least you can read a book or get up
and walk around or take a leak and then
I go on to describe some of the video
training we get a module on video I mean
a computer module on blood-borne
pathogens on what to do in the event
that pools of human blood show up on the
sales floor
all right you put on warning foot
warning cones around the puddles you don
protective gloves etc but I can't try
you know I can't stop from trying to
envision the circumstances under which
these pools of blood might arise an
associate uprising a guest riot I go
through six modules in a daze and
finally and pride away from the computer
and allowed to leave and that was the
beginning of my my career at Walmart
so the book is very much about the work
as I experienced it it was to a lesser
extent but certainly and very important
to me it's about also the people I
worked with I was not in a position you
know to interview people but you I
learned a lot just you know in the
course of working with people and these
are people who did not have do not have
the escape hatch I had you know I always
knew you know that I was really
journalists and really going home and
going back to a physically easy very
rewarding kind of work a work work that
I loved as a writer and some of the
people who left a real impression on me
and you would meet in the book or Gale
and Joan as I called them these are very
funny fast-talking hard-working
middle-aged women who it turned out were
homeless actually homeless but didn't
think they were homeless did not
consider themselves homeless because one
of them had a van to sleep in together
had a pickup truck to sleep in and that
sort of puts you in a higher stratum
somehow people also like Rosalie and
Holly as I told them who were hungry
actually hungry during the course of our
work day this was with a house cleaning
service and I must say in my with my
middle-class blinkers on you know for a
long time I thought they were just
dieting and that that's why they weren't
eating lunch and I had to you know
really eventually deduce that they just
did not have the money
the food at home for lunch or people
like George a 19 year old immigrant from
the Czech Republic who worked as a
dishwasher in a restaurant and returned
from that job at night to a dormitory
where he slept in a bed that had just
been vacated by another man who slept
during those shifts while George was
working something I thought only
happened in the 19th century so there
are not a lot of polemics in this book
but there is a message I hope that and
that is that there is something really
wrong
something very fundamentally wrong when
people can work so hard full-time
year-round and never make enough to live
on at any kind of level of comfort or
dignity so let me stop here and turn to
two quite your questions or comments and
let's see these are there in where are
they oh ok yeah ok ok no I can skip the
ones I don't know the answer to that's
what I that's what that I'm doing here
hmm
hey that's there that one either ok got
an easy question what do you think of
the role of convenience foods
restaurants and stores and their premium
prices for minimum quantity and quality
how do you think this impacts people
living on the margins well I will tell
you when I was in the Twin Cities area I
was unable to find an apartment at all
you know there was nothing below like
I'd seen available for under 800 or so a
month and I'm talking about you know I
take anything at that point I asked
around
I asked rental agents well what do I do
and they said you live in a residential
motel that's what you do and so I ended
up doing that for a while
the it was outrageous 250 dollars a week
for a room in this truly creepy motel
which I will not name again
but the one of the pointers main points
about that there's no fridge no
microwave no hot plate and that meant I
was totally dependent on convenience
stores and fast food places for food
which is a very expensive way to eat
never mind
healthy or unhealthy and the rest of
these motels were filled with with you
know families squeezed into the same
size room so that's my comment as a lot
of people are stuck with those things
I'd see in Minnesota you worked at
Walmart you know let's see it seems that
working at low-paying jobs like Walmart
leads to shopping at Walmart because of
the cost so it's a circle it's a vicious
cycle how can we beat it and this is
from three people Nathan Dane and
Victoria where are you hi yeah that's a
good question I don't think I know I
really know the answer but that's that's
true it's very cheap and it's very cheap
not only because the retail workers are
paid so little but because the people
who make the products are paid so little
you know you look at those clothing
labels you won't find anything made in
the USA you know they're made in the
third world and Walmart has been caught
well Kathy Lee you know she's one of
their brands with sweatshop labor so you
know that's where the cheapness comes
from all I can say is when you know the
workers start organizing or something
respect that effort and help and that's
but you're right the prices are low all
right here's one you mentioned on radio
on the radio of the fact that you were
told to work in many places to report to
work before discussing the pay
do you think that's a problem nationally
or just in Minnesota I've had similar
experiences with white-collar positions
yet this was an interesting discovery to
me that in jobs like this and not only
Walmart you go through this application
process other tests and everything and
then there's no there's no point in
which they call you up and say Barbara
we would like to offer you a job at X
dollars an hour will you take that no it
is lucky you Barbara you pass the test
show up tomorrow at 3 p.m. and I thought
that was so interesting to just zoom
right by that discussion that little
matter of pay so they can make you feel
like you were really lucky you passed
the test you get to work for us I don't
know if that's national but I suspect it
is because I think these are you know
large corporations let's see what do you
think of the chicken or egg theory and
speculations about poverty that is the
crime mental illness depression
homelessness chemical dependency police
profiling etc can we really say which
comes first
that is our people you know release
suffering from all these things I can't
I can't give a full answer to you know
how much depression mental illness etc
there is like it certainly homelessness
is is is well known among working people
I mean estimates are the 20% of the
homeless population of people who are
job holders and I don't know how much it
works the other way around it's for
chemical dependency and the other things
I can only say it seems to be the firm
belief of many of management in hidden
lobe especially with low paid workers
but not only low paid workers that every
single one of these employees is a
druggie a slacker and a thief you know
that's the assumption you know on day
one in one of my jobs it was a
restaurant job a fellow worker warned me
your purse can be searched at any time
ah how can that be well it can be that's
entirely legal and they just you know
they're assuming there's something wrong
with you was anyone or any organization
helpful in your search for housing in
any of the cities this is a question I
can I'll give you the answer for the
Twin Cities was I did go to a private
charity at one point I partly one I
wanted to see you know what kind of help
there would be and the recommendation
the social worker when I told her what
my wages were and then I worked at
Walmart was you should go to a shelter
and that was it
so that was kind of depressing question
did any people you spoke with think a
union might help them
what were your fellow workers opinions
of unions I can't answer I didn't you
know what's able to poll about opinions
about unions I am afraid that in
situations like Walmart sometimes the
only people thing that people know about
unions might be from that anti-union
tape they were shown except that one
very interesting thing happened a year
this was a year ago when I was here
doing this and that is that the hotel
workers went out on strike in
Minneapolis and
and that was very exciting and I know I
think it it's got people thinking
because they were Motel workers were
actually earning more than the average
Walmart workers when they started and it
did you know it's so I think defiance or
people standing up for themselves is
contagious
potentially you know it could spread
looking for looking for answerable
questions
how did question is how did you get the
jobs ie how did you hide all of your
talent that's very flattering because
the truth is a big thing about money you
know me was that I had no experience for
the jobs I was applying for except for
working in a restaurant which of course
I had done as a teenager and a college
student but I did I did not put my
entire education down on job application
forms I just thought a PhD in cell
biology you know it would it wouldn't it
would not look good they'd say what's
wrong with her
but you know no the only thing that
stood out about me in any of these jobs
was that I was had to learn I was
inexperienced and I would make the point
right here and with all the authority of
my PhD behind me if there was a lot to
learn in any job I mean I will never use
the word unskilled again in my life to
describe anything
there there is so much and and you know
it and I if I was it was a struggle in
every single job to learn the things
that I had to as well as a struggle
physically to keep up because there you
know there are jobs that don't have
brakes for example Josh I don't have
bathroom breaks okay okay question hmm
there seems to be a trend in the US over
the last twenty years towards less
compassion for those living in poverty
for example welfare reform large tax
cuts if I may edit this question tax
cuts for the rich let's put that in and
anti-union trends why is America moving
in this direction what does our future
hold I can't do the last one about what
our future holds that's up to all of us
right when we decide and what we do but
why have we been moving in this
direction
well when anybody come makes the kind of
complaints that I'm making here when
anybody raises these issues they're
usually told by someone on the right
side of the political spectrum what are
you doing that's class warm when you say
those things well the truth is the class
war was declared by the other side way
before you know and that has it
attendant then virtually you know it has
been minimally opposed
I mean unions have been weakened union
busting has become an art form even the
Democratic president who brought us
welfare reform that pulled the rug out
from under under many many poor women
and their children and you know let's
not have this class war be so one-sided
alright you know let's put that give it
a little fight okay I'm constantly
looking for simple questions
well okay here's a question by my
estimate the cost of living has risen
five times since 1974 when it was $2 per
hour no wait a minute you made me the
minimum wage this person means why then
is there no organized movement that I
know of to raise the minimum wage to at
least $10 an hour well there is you know
there has been some some of the more
liberal Democrats have been pushing to
raise the minimum wage from its present
515 an hour but I think there are also
movements and I'm sure this is true here
to produce to get a living wage locally
you do you have a living wage movement
in the Twin Cities area right
is there a representative of it here huh
okay but you know $10 an hour would not
do it there was a report released today
by jobs now from st. Paul showing that
actually you need 16 dollars an hour to
live in this area and that's not to live
in luxury that's not to live at a
middle-class standard even that is a
bare-bones type of budget to live in
this area so that's you know that's that
has to be the target in living wage
fights let me see
it's hard to read all these and let's
see how question how do you respond to
critics who have said that you did not
report in your book about fellow
employees who worked with you who are
white and had chosen to quit high school
and other things which kept them from
working in better jobs moving up etc I
didn't know of these people I'm sorry
nobody told me that they had just chosen
to quit high school etc and I you know I
mean I I wanted the dress did not
protect you know something that is
associated with this question which I
sometimes run into was people saying
sort of well what's wrong with these
people why don't they go to school
raise themselves up well you know first
there are a lot of obstacles up to that
you know what you get stuck in a trap
it's expensive to be poor you know
you've got if you have for example some
of the you're living in a residential
motel for example you often don't
control your hours you might want to go
to night school but then suddenly you're
working the night shift and there that
goes but I think the real the the what I
feel most though about this question
though is that we need to realize that
people in a lot in our low-wage job
force in the United States are doing
work we depend on it's not you know
somebody's got to do these things I
worked in a nursing home briefly in
Maine that's important work I felt good
about that I mean somebody has toward
work in the store somebody is going to
serve the food why do we say what's
wrong with these people to do it when we
need it done why not pay them and expect
them for
okay hmm nope can't sorry what are my
hopes for the books in terms of policy
changes I will I think I this you know
the things that we would need to do in
terms of social policy are very familiar
to this this crowd I would just you know
some things that just struck me very
strongly coming from this experiences of
course the need for national health
insurance I mean in so many you know is
that you know other countries have it
why can't we I mean they Canadians have
it are they so different you know that's
not a strange exotic country they they
survive but you know I a lot of these
employers will offer health insurance
but the amount the employee has to
contribute is so great it could be
hundreds of dollars a month with a
family that it's not possible you know
it's just not a personally we need that
we need subsidized child care for
working parents you know that's again
other countries have that high quality
child care too by the way we need we
need to make to bring some reality to
the right to organize and bargain
collectively that is a right you know as
it exists on paper but it's not enforced
by the government you can be fired for
anything and that's one thing that was
really brought home to me and these
experiences how easy it is to be fired
for breaking a little rule like a
Walmart you can't say damn or hell and
you can imagine the other words you
can't say either and you know and I have
read I did not experience it's the
people who were involved in union
organizing have been fired Walmart
because if that's but that's illegal so
what they're fired for is saying damn
you know and so those all those little
rules the afl-cio estimates that 10,000
American workers are fired every year
for union activity that is that means
we're not that that right doesn't really
exist so those would be some of my
policy changes let's see here's somebody
he says Corbin somewhere it is here
he says wonderful thank you then he says
next time do it without a car Corbin you
do it without a car all right I mean I
would see these people you know standing
at the bus stops at the edge to see the
jobs are often in the periphery of the
Twin Cities some of the cheap housing is
in the center I would see these people
who would have you know an hour commute
each day I that I I can't imagine how I
would have done that
see you mentioned some of the advantages
you had in seeking and maintaining
employment did you notice any
differences faced by workers of color
and I can't say I was in the position to
survey that I would say what I think I
did notice was that when I was initially
applying at these big discount hotels
for hotel housekeeping jobs some reason
I thought that was going to be easier
than waitressing I would always be
steered toward waitressing and I think
that was because I was white and
english-speaking but I you know and
actually if if it had been a better
season when I was working it would have
been more lucrative to be in waitressing
but that was the extent to which I was
able to note that sort of bias no that's
our that let's see no I don't know any
mexican-american men in the building
trades not yet but would like to meet
them
the question to what extent did
financial illiteracy contribute to the
dilemma of your fellow workers and what
do you think our culture would look like
if we all left high school knowledgeable
and skilled in financial matters ah I
don't think you had to be very
financially literate to figure you know
when you've got seven dollars an hour to
play with I mean there's not a lot of a
lot of big high-powered mathematical
things to deal with you just you know
you just can't spend money I I don't I
don't know I mean I did I did meet
people who'd gotten caught up in credit
card debt
and that but you know that goes into the
middle class I mean that's not just a
problem of poor people but that you know
that is a really sneaky addictive kind
of thing and I am very disturbed by the
recent Congress's recent changes in the
bankruptcy law which will of course
penalize the poor and not the credit
card companies which act you know like
drug dealers really in the way they you
know recruit people let's see
no looking for easy ones
what has your work history banned
besides the recent jobs for this book
prior to becoming a journalist well I
did waitress and do things like that
when I was a teenager
perhaps I should add that in my extended
family and in my immediate nuclear
family there are plenty of people whose
lives have been ended these kinds of
jobs so there was not a new it wasn't a
new category of for me of people you
know or something it wasn't a strange
social environment or should I say you
know I actually this is a good point to
say something that I would toward the
end of every job I would always
tell somebody or group of people that I
knew particularly well what I was really
doing there you know and I would be
nervous about that and that cuz you know
I hadn't said that I'm not doing this
for the money I'm on a mission and so I
would get up my nerve and I would say
look I've got to tell you something and
then I'd say I'm really a writer any
response was always like uh yeah and you
know what I finally realized was
everybody's a writer you know is it that
you know I was that people who are
writing poems who are writing capturing
and keeping journals writing a book even
in some cases and I think that's
important to realize that it's not like
some different sort of people
intellectually speaking who are in our
you know you know do in the low-wage
work force so I consider living with a
roommate why why not well I didn't
really know anybody and you know that
what I couldn't figure out how to how to
do that but still open to possibilities
there let's see what do okay question
what do you advise for workers stuck in
the [ __ ] and the downward mobility of
constant job loss and reemployment and
this is from said Wendy who talks about
having short term jobs holiday rushes
and then seasonal jobs etc I I don't I
don't know how'd you get out of that but
I do think ultimately you know if you're
stuck if you're in one job for a while
it's a matter even if you know however
you do it making connections with other
people they're building some kind of
solidarity some kind of network of
friendship and support to of whether
maybe it's going to lead to you're
approaching a union
maybe it's just going to lead to the you
as a group being able to say to
management we need some changes here but
I don't think it's really possible all
alone you know what we do I love that
old Union word solidarity you know
sometimes we do have we do have to band
together to make change and one more
okay
well question how did the research and
writing of nickel and dimed change you
as a person I would I would say the big
difference it makes as made to me is
that I see people differently I don't
think I was ever completely oblivious to
all the people who make my life possible
say the hotel cleaners and the serving
people and everything I don't think it
was completely oblivious but now I see
them in a different way I mean when I
for example go into a Food Mart in a gas
station and see the woman behind the
counter now I'm thinking how long has
she been on her feet today what is she
going home to you know was she's going
home to chill to feed children at the
end of the day and what will what will
it be will it be a trailer will it be a
motel will be crammed crammed into a
house with other people so I think yeah
I I see things differently
and some of that is uncomfortable
because it means seeing the pain but we
all have to see that pain if we're going
to bring about change thank you
for more about barbara ehrenreich and
her work visit barbara ehrenreich
dot-com
you